now the reason I have this on the board
is because I want to tell you a very
very brief story how many of you can
would say you can play basketball hands
up like you know the rules you know how
to play yep hands up straight
almost everyone okay think here hands
down so when I was in year eight I
thought I was okay as a basketball
player I quite enjoyed the game except
there's this teeny little problem
that my friends do a really good bass
complaint my school players Tommy which
was that I was unable to do a layoff do
you know what a layup is no laugh is
like as the name suggests right you
meant to get nice and close jump up and
then you literally lay the ball up into
the hoop that's the idea right except I
was super short as a year 8 student like
I was the second shorter person in the
grade including girls so I couldn't get
anywhere close and so I could not do the
layout now I thought that was ok and
then my friends who basketball said we
hate to break it to you but the layup is
like the basic scoring shot that's like
the basic thing that's like the first
thing you do after dribbling if you
can't layup it's like sorry dude you
can't you don't have your ABCs of
basketball ok now what you're going to
be learning today is kind of like the
layup of algebra is the basic building
block it's like your bread and butter to
change metaphors ok it's not a
complicated thing but you're going to be
doing a lot of it soon as you're very
good at it ok so what I want you to
write underneath this heading is first a
bit of a review right underneath this
would you please write with me a premium
rule a premium rule and then in brackets
can someone give me some examples of
some common pronumerals that we use yeah
go ahead X is probably the most common
one what else might you see yeah a
another one when you use a number we
often use the letter and for number ok
and you know what this can just keep on
going you can use anything you like
right you could use like a shape you
could use a word if you wanted anything
that can stand in front of a numeral but
these tend to be the most you know
rather than saying or draw like a funky
looking star these are easy things we
know how to draw right a pruning rule is
a symbol
that stands in place all and do you
remember this is our definition right
I'm just going to go back to what this
means it says in place of what what is
the symbol stand in place of it's in the
word itself yeah go ahead
yeah just a number just a numeral of any
kind right so a perennial is just
something that stands in place of a
number okay now substitution is what
it's called when we take that pretty
rule and we swap it for a number right
it might be like an answer or it might
be you know the length of a particular
shape if we put the number back in where
the pronumeral was that's what we mean
by substitution that was a long sentence
let me state that a little more simply
substitution is the replacement of that
symbol with a number that's all that
means
okay big fancy word very simple idea
substitution is the replacement of the
symbol with a number
okay so let's think of a quick example
of this right if for instance and you
don't have to do this I'm going to try
and do better than this if you had a
suckle right thumb better you guys
learned if you recall ah see the area of
a circle there's a formula for it does
anyone remember what it was
area equals yes a handy PI R squared
very good PI squared so you can see we
have a couple of lecture we have three
pronumerals in here sorry that's a very
messy PI it looks like three hours
altogether that's a bit better we've got
three printables here don't we there's
an A and then there's the pi and then
there's an R right
what is the placed and fall by the way
it always stands for the same thing
every single time Mary yeah 3.14 oh no
no no no no no no no 9 and I'm not going
to ask you to say all of the digits
because we'd be here forever ok so it
stands for a number
what's the H stand for hmm it's the area
it's what we're trying to calculate
right if we're trying to work out how
big this is and the our course stands
for radius very good so as an example
right we could and I'm actually going to
get us to write the words for this we
could substitute a particular value for
the radius of that circle I'm just going
to ask you guys to eyeball this with me
that circle there the one thing I've
drawn on the board what does the radius
look like to you roughly it's about like
from the center to about there right
what do you reckon 10 I'm pretty sure
it's bigger than 5 like what that's like
5 yeah I'm gonna call it like 15 15 are
you count of 15
let's just go to 15 if I substituted R
equals 15 into a equals PI squared what
would that mean well instead of saying R
every time I see our I'm going to
replace it there's that word there I'm
going to substitute it with the number
with the value that it takes okay so in
this case that would be a is equal to PI
and I'm gonna write it as closely as I
can to what I had before
I'm gonna put a multiplication sign in
there 15 squared right now some of you
might be really good with your times
tables you might already know what 15
squared is can anyone tell me what it is
sure you're 25 very good okay so you got
it really quickly and so therefore my
next line is going to be 225 tend to
write the number first when you've got
other letters like playing around pi and
that would be the area of the circle but
I think it's really important and I'm
actually gonna highlight this if you
have another color that'd be really
fantastic see this line in here okay
this is what we call the substitution
line I've written it exactly as you saw
it before PI R squared even though you
guys could tell me what 15 squared was
quickly I still want to write 15 squared
there so I can see I'm swapping it for
what's there right so this is the
substitution line okay